my boys con un altro livello c'è una
motosega Ah questa qua è utile per
spaccare tutto va bene
Ah perché c'ha il bottone sotto Ma dai
sto male Allora aspetta che qua è
complicata la situazione bella però
bella no l'avevo visto però tutto ok
Let's go ragazzi Allora ehm qua abbia
Bisogna scendere piano però perché qua
la situazione è drastica cos'è questo
non facciamo domande ragazzi e anche il
secondo handà Ho schiacciato mi indica
che ce l'ha sotto qualcosa ma non vedo
cosa Cos'è che c'è Ah c'è una porta se
io cado qua muoio com'è possibile Devo
lanciare la testa mi lancio la testa
raga Vediamo se funziona Let's go
Oddio ce l'ho fatta con la testa
incredibile Beh no vabbè ragazzi però
sti laser non esistono Eh ve lo dico
Non so cosa ho fatto Non ne ho idea però
va bene
Ma sì che te ne fai la gamba che te ne
fai vamos e anche qua il tasto è